[Music]
fifteen years 15 years connecting the
disconnected
fifteen years believing in a
revolutionary future
fifteen years accelerating ubiquitous
full fiber connectivity
created a momentum around fiber helped
bring about a sustainable future full of
opportunity all enabled by
fiber-to-the-home connectivity which
brings a better quality of life an
increased economic competitiveness
all because of you the members and
supporters of the FTD age council Europe
you are the engine that fuels our
[Music]
view the technology innovators that is
Raptors the fiber operators The
Ambassadors have fiber pioneers with
more than 150 members and many more
partners we are promoting full fiber
high speed connectivity for everyone
everywhere together we find our future
and the future is bright
5g virtual reality visual recognition
systems artificial intelligence
revolutionary developments in a healthy
smart cities and homes and having
glimpsed the future the opportunities
are endless fiber is needed everywhere
and it is new that will deliver this
vision are you in
welcome to the FTTH conference 2019
you